a silent revolution is changing the UK's
public services in councils and police
forces workers are seeing a future
literally what we've looked at is all
the children have been sexually
exploited in the city they are making
decisions using computer models sold on
the promise that they can detect
problems before they happen the more I
learned about how much data and how
these systems are being used I am
shocked daily it sounds like science
fiction but unseen and largely
unregulated these predictive algorithms
are changing lives computer service
Kenya it's gotta be human decision and
raising profound questions about who or
what is actually in charge as soon as I
she was born and her birth was
registered
she became data to understand predictive
algorithms you need to start looking at
the world in this way seeing everyone
and everything as an entry on a
spreadsheet Ayesha's mam Moana gets it
as a 14 year old she fled the civil war
in Somalia and waited years to see if
her plight met the UK's Asylum
requirements now age 32 she's being
measured again as a single mum relying
heavily on counsel support my daily
medication we met murder at a food bank
in the north of Bristol no income that's
why I get help from my health visitor
she referred me to the food bank and
they gave me functions that helps that
keeps us going for a couple of weeks
in one of Bristol's biggest police
stations we find the destination of Mona
and ayissha's data the Bristol
integrated analytics hub run by Gary
Davies takes in records of benefits
school attendance crime homelessness
teenage pregnancy and even mental health
from 54,000 local families to British
which children will suffer domestic
violence be sexually exploited or go
missing what we do is we have a look at
all the children we already know go
missing multiple times and we learn what
their characteristics look like so that
we get a really detailed understanding
of their profile and then what the
system does is it will look at children
who start to go missing and then say
whether they are similar in profile to
those children that went missing
multiple times Gary shows me the record
for one teenager flagged for early
intervention a missing person risk
seventy five out of a hundred
yes that's right 82 out of a hundred
four child that's right yeah it'll give
us a scoring with a kind of banding of a
like a high medium or low and also it
will give us information about why that
profile is saying that what it isn't
doing is isn't saying computer says yes
or no what it's saying is although
actually yes yeah it's what it's saying
is yes there's a risk but what it's now
saying is that that's not making
decisions about you or your life no one
thinks ayisha's in danger but all the
same how welfare is being policed by an
algorithm and under the current law no
one had to ask Mona's permission Jen
person is on a mission she wanted the
world to wake up to the dangers of data
I was a a mum with three young children
who just started primary school and knew
very little about how information about
them was being collected never thought
about it and then a friend on the school
room said to me have you seen how the
government's going to collect or your GP
records your medical records and send
them to
national database and I thought that's
wrong gende isn't less smart toy spy on
her children she wouldn't even let us
film their pictures her fear is that the
unique individuality of a child is being
sacrificed for the sake of efficiency we
know local authorities have already had
40 percent cuts to their budgets and
technology is being used as a
replacement to try and patch up a system
which is missing out on people is
missing out on people power and we're
trying to use software to solve these
social issues which it doesn't have the
power to do I tell her what Gary told me
that it's the human social worker who
makes the decision people have a
tendency to trust the computer and
whilst it's advertised as being able to
help you make a decision
often in reality it replaces your human
decision and you you have that sort of
faith in the computer that is always
going to be right predictive algorithms
sound like something out of Minority
Report but you've probably used one in
the last 24 hours
the Amazon recommendation engine
predicts what you'll want to buy the
Facebook suggested France feature
predicts who you'll know Google
autocomplete you choose recommend your
videos none of these systems tell you
what to do but they definitely give you
a nudge and crucially they frame your
sense of what's available
they take the past and say the future
would look like this working with
researchers at Cardiff University we've
compiled the most comprehensive map of
predictive algorithms in the UK it
wasn't easy
there is almost no oversight of this new
field we found 53 local authorities
predicting everything from bin
collections to benefit sanctions but the
most enthusiastic pioneers with these 14
police forces - police officers
copy that were making our way there now
it's Saturday night in Maidstone in Kent
and PCs Lee Ann Stark and John Finley
responding to an incident in the same
cubicle son decided to boot barriers and
bentham Charlie's come all the way from
Essex for this big annual night out
now datapoint part of an algorithm
designed to save time and money for Kent
stretched police force they do not stand
a finger at my home expenses do not
mention when questioned something like
around report anything say may be given
in evidence
zenthon you don't understand about
stabbing around the corner persons not
currently breathing open chest wounds
everyone's just trying to run out to
their now move jump out and let will go
with the van but this gentleman is
custody one live one else guys come on
jump out don't want to see there's so
much more important stuff right now
because you just wouldn't go the problem
for Kent Police is the days of work it
takes to follow up cases like Charlie's
so now they ask an algorithm called EBIT
whether their investigation will be
successful it's used for 1/3 of all
crime in Kent if it helps identify so
what inquiry these we made witnesses
CCTV and it helps us through the picture
of where we're going to move forward
with the investigation
two hours later and the stabbing has
become a murder investigation looking at
this it's obvious why the police need
time-saving algorithms but to evict him
it's not clear why their crime should be
forgotten on a computer's say-so
Julie is data but not in the way she
wants it's quite where she lives in
rural Kent although she does have some
noisy neighbors you've got them when
they were about three months old and
they were pretty big then to be fair
they've got a lot bigger one day were
alone at home
Julie interrupted two men stealing her
husband's tools I came around here said
what are you doing as I said it one
jumped out the van holding tools and the
other one stood here and I was standing
there and her with a crowbar basically
told me to back off this threatening
behavior is exactly the kind of crime
that gets run through a bit when that
fella was holding the crowbar but my
head he laughed at me he actually
laughed and at the time that when it
happened I was always scared but after
that was just so angry just do that to
people where say a livelihood it's we're
working I just think they can take what
they want before Kemp police began using
its predictive algorithm it pursues
around 75% of cases now it investigates
40% with Julie's case among those
dropped message it was left on my phone
you know they've done their inquiries
and there's nothing else they can do is
and it's going on file although the
force says it investigates all
burglaries and the EBIT is 98 percent
accurate you can't go and the computer
says can you it's got to be an human
decision basically yeah why is that
because it's personal to me it's
personal it's messed up our lives up
it's you know to completely change their
life I asked Jen about that ninety-eight
percent figure she says it reflects the
problems with all products of algorithms
they're based on the faulty data of the
past so the only reaffirm our prejudices
the more that you see these systems you
realize there is a huge amount of
unfairness built into them
from the beginning because their data
are often inaccurate or incomplete when
are we going to stop and say that's not
right anymore
it's not fair it's discriminatory lip
elixir is a former gang member and he
feels disadvantaged by his data
hey girl you can drink your drinkers age
27 he's now a family man with three
daughters and another one on the way but
he can't escape his teenaged track
record from ages of a bar 14 to 20 I say
what the majority at a time I'll get
stopped at least once or twice a day VP
Singh one of the biggest predictive
algorithms in the UK the Metropolitan
Police's gangs matrix which the Met used
to track and target possible gang
members Lippe was one but even though
he's reformed sell it three men come in
and cross their arms and look at you
take your clothes off and if see
instructions yes squat lift up your
scrotum
the gangs matrix used an algorithm to
flag people as green amber or red
according to their perceived level of
danger
the police the police back in there
lippy wishes he wasn't on the matrix now
but at the time he saw his ranking
almost as a challenge confusing thing to
be a part of that something to tell you
trying to turn I hired by I remember
feeling a sense although poor thing
you're not so you know about me then
alright
the gangs matrix had even bigger
problems the met put victims of gang
crime on it and kept them there even if
they posed no risk practices condemned
by the UK's data watchdog
although the Met told us it did not
directly discriminate against any
particular community the youngest person
on the gangs matrix was 12 and 88% of
its subjects a black or ethnic minority
in many ways computers are smarter than
we are
so they may know what's best for us but
as we go about our lives we assume we're
making our own decisions
and we expect that we'll be treated in
the same way as everyone else with
predictive algorithms that won't always
be the case in the digital age we are
all data but will we like the way we're
being processed
you